how's gum resin is pa-pow today we're
gonna play some more Sims 4 i modded the
game with some little streets that
hopefully will show after in today's
intercourse in today's whatever it's
called there's our beautiful house I'm
just kidding this is our house ass bill
with the holy gnomes it's probably the
best house of infinity oh there's a girl
she's just standing there maybe we have
found a partner for Chan go Jane he's
coming sorry I am she goes away right
away ask about the day do you like
dinosaurs so what a great way to ask
about the day he's like touching a
bullet or told you we're really hitting
it off here look at these double twice
is all around
alright I'm gonna ask if she's single
this is the first time ever China's
flirted with someone new and they have
not completely rejected him oh god
totally oh my god
all right there we're on a date Chan is
creeping up on her what is she going
where's she going the barbecue she just
couldn't stop herself from making those
burgers and Chinese is alone in the
distance now what are you doing don't
hit on other girls while you're on a
date Chang oh so I'm talking to her
while I'm playing chess with her what is
this two-timing business teach me your
way and there's a third woman involved
even how great of a hipster or a hobo
has sit down to eat with us alright
let's invite her back to our house oh
god I asked him on a date I was gonna
add actually no and they got - I didn't
mean to ask him on a date what are you
doing this is the worst date of my life
yeah this is not weird at all she's just
drinking her milk as always what well
Chinese sleeping okay she's being very
creepy she's being like that girl from
Paranormal Activity oh god I can see
Chan's ass
it's so pretty can we see you hit okay
oh god what is that Chinese Chinese it's
just oh my god that is mad
Oh God that is nasty Wow we hate each
other now
look ah alright next woman well [ __ ] you
then life is too short to waste it with
you alright here's an old lady let's
just try with her we have to stick with
our age she has nice negatives all I
want is from a man Chan to get laid it's
not too much to ask
she hates us now great goddamn hipsters
keep sitting down without 40 things
maybe Shan is gay I think Shan is gay I
I can't explain him being this terrible
with women otherwise oh god I can see
her naked Jesus Christ that is
disturbing what the [ __ ] are those
badonkadonks that is this [ __ ] up why
did I install this mod our new mission
is to find a man let's go and knock her
on yeah a real man a handyman oh my god
he I dressed so nicely another hugging
that's adorable
okay but this is not chance true
intentions
make a flirtatious joke God work just
work yes is he responding to it yes blow
a kiss yes it's it hot in here or is it
just me we're totally I know it was gay
I didn't know I was gay no but I know
Ted was gay I don't want to mess
anything up now
first kiss here it comes here it comes
hashtag chichi licks working I tried so
hard with all the women and here's the
answer all I have to do is flirt with
myself what it's almost chance time and
make sure you make most of these what
he's gonna die already
China needs to get laid at least once
we need egg move things faster with
Felix man let's make all the babies oh
it's happening oh yeah hey what is
happening underneath there I don't want
to know Chad got laid before he died yes
with me though that's the catch but I'll
take it and they're doing it again
he's just Christ wait they're both
throwing up are they both pregnant
there's something wait wait wait wait
hold on your horses it's inside what I
think I thought it was getting fat but I
think Chinese pregnant
finally God it took him forever no
[ __ ] way I'm pregnant too
I'm pregnant too I don't know how
pregnancy works but I don't think this
is how they do it so you can barely see
it on me though it looks like I have a
beer belly or something that's the great
thing about men if we get pregnant we
can just hide it off and say we got fat
Chinese whaling to her pregnancy and and
is excited to be a mother
great I don't know if I want to see this
Satan's for honey bee look at him look
at it Chan what the [ __ ] have the baby
and you have the baby - let's have them
at this exact same time baby
ass as to what why are they black I mean
I thought channelization what they oh
he's oh he is black okay I almost
thought I always saw him as Asian I
don't know why every habit to beautiful
babies born by two beautiful men nothing
weird here I hope you enjoyed this
episode if you did go ahead and hit that
like button and subscribe to become
abroad today that's all for me for now
stay awesome